[Music]
brian is with us brian's in
pittsburgh how are you brian
dave i'm good thanks for taking a minute
to talk with me my pleasure sir how can
we help i want to tell you uh
about six weeks ago i ran into a friend
of mine that retired
and he was telling me how great it was
and asked me how much longer do you have
i said 12 years
and he started telling me get ready
debt free that's the only way to go i
hear him
don't pay a lot of attention to it my
son tells me a week after that hey
i'm listening to this ramsay show never
heard of it before i said what is your
new howard stern i don't know never
heard of
yes he howard's got much better hair
than i've got
yeah so he tells me this a couple more
times i'm on a trip for work i got a lot
of windshield time i turn it on
i listen to six podcasts back to back to
back and i'm gonna tell you i'm hooked i
get it i am bought in
wow so i heard you say hey you gotta
know
everything that's going out everything
is coming in and what's your debt
so i did that i spent about 30 hours on
that last week
and let me tell you it's uh scary it's
emotional it was tough
and so i've got
some debt and my question for you is
i have about 12 000 and change that we
have invested in the stock market single
stocks
and is it smarter to leave that there as
a savings i know there's a risk there
and or is it better to pull every penny
out of that
and put it towards the debt that we have
and that would that might would take
care of uh
i don't know 20 25 of it
but my goal i mean i want to be
debt-free i got 12 more years to retire
and i want to be debt-free when we get
there and i wanted to do it and then my
wife spot in on it now
okay so you got about fifty thousand
dollars worth of debt and twelve
thousand dollars in stock
66 247 to be exact all right good deal
what's your household income
uh about 180 190 annually okay all right
so you've been listening and you know
some of the lingo now
and some of the process and the baby
steps and all of that right
and so baby step two is where you are
paying off all debt
except a house using the debt snowball
listing your debts smallest to largest
paying minimum payments on everything
but the little one attacked the little
one
we stop all investing temporarily
and we use all money that we can get our
hands on that
is not in a retirement account to throw
at baby step two
and that's a standard baby step two
answer
which would lead us to cashing out your
stock and paying off a fourth of your
debt
okay not saving like you're when you
talk about emergency funds i mean leave
that there i mean we got no cash
savings how much cash do you have
uh i don't know 11 12 grand something
like that okay we always baby step one
is one thousand dollars saved anything
above that
goes on baby step two until baby step
two is done and so i'm gonna use that
money as well down to one thousand
dollars which is going to scare the pee
wadding out of you by the way
that scares the hell out of that i know
i know and that's it should
but you're not going to live there for
very long because
now we've paid off uh 23
000 of your 66 000
uh if i did my math right just now
and you have enough income to clear the
rest of it very very quickly
and as soon as it's cleared then the
first order of business is baby step
three and that's build your emergency
fund
back up to a full three to six months of
expenses
which it's not now it's kind of it's
kind of anemic right now it's weak
right the two together would make a
decent emergency fund if you didn't have
any debt but
that's what we teach and here's the
reason
it's not to induce fear but the fear
will also help be one of your motivators
that oh crap moment you just had that
thing where your stomach just kind of
jumped up in your throat just at the
mere suggestion of doing this and we
hadn't even done it
but just the idea you go you know we all
do that we all have a physical reaction
to that
um that is going to drive you to stick
with the plan
now to suggest that you keep a 1 000
emergency fund for five years or
something would be ludicrous and i don't
suggest that
but we're talking about just a mere
months here again what was your
household income
uh 180 190. okay so how fast do you pay
off 50 thousand dollars
six months 40 or no i'm sorry 40 000
like what i mean less than six months
right
well my goal was two years i wanted to
do it before i'm 50. so that's that
sucks
that's way too much rocks you make 180
000
a year i need 40 000 of 180.
this is six months how much does this is
five thousand i want five thousand
dollars a month on this dad
i want you to smack the crap out of it
all right and then you're so you're done
by christmas dude
now chris by christmas you're starting
to rebuild this emergency fund
from one thousand dollars up and then as
soon as you've got that three to six
months of expenses then you restart your
401k oh by the way you put money in the
401k right now
i took your advice and i backed it down
to the uh
minimum that the company matches okay
that wasn't my advice my advice was stop
it
i'll stop it all together well i
misunderstood i thought you you were
saying get you know don't let free money
go to the company matches
no no no not when you're in the hole man
you're just getting started on all this
you're trying
so what i'm what i'm doing is i'm not
making fun of you and i'm not picking at
you but i'm giving you the
the the detail that you haven't gotten
in the last couple weeks of exposure yet
and so what i need to do is i'm going to
send you the the game plan
with all the nuanced detail the baby
steps on steroids it's the
best-selling book called the total money
makeover and we'll give it to you as a
gift
hold on kelly's going to pick up i'm
going to mail you one and you read that
thing and your wife read that thing
and you'll see what i'm talking about
180 minus 40 you can make it on
okay 90 minus 40. 90 in the next six
months
minus 40 and you're done by christmas
you can make it on and i just
put 11 and 12 on the debt so i know i
put 23 out of there so it's 43 left
and so yeah you're there you're going to
be there
and that's that's what i would do if i
woke up in your shoes the
the uh the great news is you've you've
found a new thing here
and you're fired up about it but it's
about to get real
so imagine you imagine this this is this
is the feeling you had brian when you
put you
spent 30 hours and you put that debt
down
and you got emotional that's you
on the plains of africa and you're a
a gazelle and you just stuck your head
up and you just saw that lying in the
grass
and now you gotta take off running man
and that's what the next six seven
months is gonna be it's gonna be
a all-out gut-wrenching sprint because
they're all intensity that's right
because they're coming for you man
they're coming you gotta ride
i wanna mention this i don't want this
to fly by dave i know this makes me
sound sappy
it takes a special level of courage for
a grown man making this kind of money
which means he's got some kind of
he's got some some ego some strength his
son
came in and said dad i think you should
look at this and most dads in this
situation go
shut up and he listened he just
listened that the approach on the call
was humble it was
a humble call and i want everybody out
there if your son comes says hey can we
just talk dad
take that talk take that that breakfast
take that conversation man
um that took a lot of courage for a son
to do and i'm proud of him but i'm proud
of that dad for listening man that's
cool yeah it doesn't happen very often
cool
brunch got up he's got a thing going he
does man
he's uh comfortable in his own skin yeah
strong
but making good decisions so yeah you're
gonna you're gonna go do this brian and
and then you're gonna call us back do
your debt free scream we're gonna hear a
great story from you it's gonna be
awesome what i love about brian is i
guarantee he's a leader
and as a leader he approached this with
the appropriate skepticism and then he
did the math
and then as a good leader he went oh
crap you know what i mean
that's a good leader man not that
everything's perfect not that i got to
come up with some stupid excuse but i
can see the data and i can go
whoops we need to change course quickly
right yeah i don't think i did that one
right
i love it man i love it that's this is
there's a formula here for everybody
listening
yeah that that you know involves life
change
you know bible says be not conformed to
this world yeah
this world's broke yep i mean normal is
looking good
and no money yep normal is you're
driving a car with a
big butt payment on it normal is you've
got a student loan that's been around so
long you think it's a pet
normal is you know you've discovered
master
card yes and discovered bondage in
american distress
this is normal normal sucks but it looks
good
everybody's walking around the smile on
their light on their faces
living in the land of denial and you
know i'm not talking about a river in
egypt
you know i mean seriously but when you
stick your head up and you go game on
baby
i'm not gonna be normal anymore be not
conformed to this world be
transformed by what brian's doing the
renewing of your mind
new information will set you free baby